one of the key features of the new
curriculum is a is a much increased
emphasis on leadership education in the
very first full quarter we expose the
students to critical analytical thinking
in in small seminar groups which really
encourages future leaders to think about
the really tough issues that leaders
will have to face in practice we also
ask the students in the fall to really
reflect on their own leadership styles
and skills as well as other leadership
styles that they might aspire to and to
think behaviorally about the skills that
they need to go from where they are now
to where they need to be and we do that
through the leadership labs in the
leadership labs the students practice
exercises of this kind and they do it
with mentors and in particular we draw
in second-year arbuckle leadership
fellows to help them do that in these
exercises so through experiential
learning as well as seminar based
discussions and conventional classes in
all of these ways we're touching on
various aspects of leadership we are
offering a new elective on on practical
ethics where again seasoned managers
will come in and present the students
with vignettes of ethical dilemmas that
they faced in their careers and and put
the students in that managers shoes and
ask them to think through the the
various issues of how you would approach
the dilemma in practice in real time and
just as importantly what you might have
done differently in the first place if
possible to have prevented that dilemma
from Herat from arising